[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the gorilla collective a
three-day digital festival of game
announcements
trailers and demos streams straight to
you
please welcome your host game awards
trending gamer
greg miller welcome back to the final
day of the guerrilla collective for the
last two days we've been showing you
brand new games
debuting trailers and even releasing
titles on the spot but today is my
favorite day honestly
today the developers are going to speak
directly to you about their projects in
a laid back live stream you of course
hang out in the chat
they show you their cool games and we
all get to find our next favorite
title sound good then ladies and
gentlemen let's get into it this
is your final day of the gorilla
collective alex justin
take it away what is happening everybody
welcome to the gorilla collective
day three it has been an amazing
experience the last two days
we are showing over 80 games we got
seven games today that we're gonna be
showcasing
uh and a little bit about me i am the
co-founder of the media indie exchange
the mix
i helped to produce the gorilla
collective along with some of the most
amazing
producers i mean publishers and
developers from around the world
i'm also a game developer and that type
of thing and i'm gonna chop it up with
you guys
and sitting next to me is the amazing oh
alex wilmer thank you uh yeah i'm alex
warmer
uh i co-founded an audio production
company
uh here in berkeley um
we also have studios in uh
south korea and in ireland and we work
around the clock on video games animated
cartoon series
film that kind of yeah and we're here in
wilmer sound i mean
uh just a little bit about the gorilla
collective like i was saying um
due to the lack of e3 we were like let's
get together the mix
and a bunch of publishers and developers
and let's do this thing ourselves
independently
um so what you see around here we
basically built up a studio within his
studio to make this happen and we've
been grinding to make this happen along
with the developers here
um so this is gonna be a really cool
experience we have uh like i said seven
games coming up
and uh last week we did uh the black
voices
in gaming stream which is amazing and
it's just been crazy as everyone knows a
covet black lives matter that type
all those things happening um we do have
a charity
if you can pop the charity up you can
those are our sponsors but it's all good
yeah so
we do have a charity that you could
donate through tiltify the naacp
unicef and game heads um if you want to
donate
anything that you you put forth for that
is very very helpful
um so the next couple hours we'll be
showing you games
chat with teams learn more about these
games amazing creators like some of them
i'm a fanboy for
i guess i bet you guys are too and check
out the chat because
they are in the chat even though you
guys are clowning folks
the cylinder is coming towards the end
of the show guys
um yeah but let's roll over to our first
trailer and get right into it
this is iron harvest
peggy 18. we were all busy with our
own small lives didn't know what went on
in secret
didn't see the war coming
they said the war would be worn within
months
an adventure promising pride and honor
in the end it would be five years
years of torment and horror like the
world had never seen before
the great war that was supposed to end
all wars is over
while in secret the seed is sown
for the next war
[Music]
but this time we're vigilant
and we'll fight
it's
[Music]
and that was the dope trailer for iron
harvest we got tobias on the line
um talking about the game we're going to
be playing the game this dude is going
to be driving
hey what's up how's it going hey hey
thank you for having me guys
that's you got like you look really
crispy right now the beard is
is exquisite by the way
yeah on point oh nice
nice so yeah um i was we were playing
through the game
the other day um the demo and the game
is really interesting just
i mean did you did you guys have a
kickstarter back in the
like a while ago yes that that's right
everything started with the kickstarter
it was uh
in 2018 if i remember correctly and yeah
so
that's a kickstarter uh project and now
two years after
we are right in front of releasing the
game so that's
we're super excited about that that's
dope because i remember when the kick
i was actually i don't know if you heard
about fig but i actually uh was
publishing at fig and i was like looking
through games
and when you guys were on kickstarter i
was like oh my god this is so awesome
you had such
great artwork and and animatics and that
type of stuff that you were showcasing i
was like i can't wait for this game to
come out
and then when i saw that you guys were
you're uh pushing your game for
you know to showcasing the gorilla clip
i was like oh my god we have to play
this and then
right now uh so let's let's
switch alex is going to be playing i
it's so interesting that you guys
chose to uh to start with this kind of
um tutorial where you're actually little
kids i was like this is
fascinating and amazing yes
exactly so uh the game for those who
don't know it's an rts right so a
real-time strategy game but here in this
tutorial
we somehow need to teach the people how
how the mechanics work right so we
thought it's a pretty cool
uh way to make it in this kind of
uh snow fight scene because not only
does it give you the
uh like basics of the game but it also
gives you some
background story of the main characters
of the game because this young lady
there is ana who's the hero for the
polanya faction
and it gives the characters actually way
more
substance i'd say yeah for sure
it's always good to have like an organic
feel when you're doing that as opposed
to just being this like
really stiff like you have to read a
bunch of texts
you know a bunch of texts but what was
your uh
i don't know press a and d to move the
camera and stuff so here it's like a
little bit more
gamification right yeah that's the word
i guess
yeah true
so what was your uh what was the
inspiration behind
uh iron harvest
so uh yeah it's the biggest
like gameplay-wise the biggest
inspiration are games like company of
heroes dawn of war and warcraft 3.
so it's more this uh classical rts and
like gameplay where's the closest is
probably company of heroes if you
remember that game where you have to
take cover
you cannot just simply send your troops
to the front line you have to
protect them and keep them alive because
they are very precious and very
expensive
so it's a very tactical and strategic
rts actually
and from the world and the design
it's inspired and uh by
jakob kruzhalski's which is a polish
artist his artwork
and he actually created this 1920 plus
universe that's
uh also in the name iron harvest there
is like a subtitle 1920 plus
that's the name of the universe and in
this universe you have an
alternative post world war one uh where
the people instead of tanks were using
giant max actually to uh uh
yeah to to fight and um we call this
era the diesel punk area so steampunk is
a little bit earlier
cyberpunk later and this 1900s the
diesel punk
era and that's where we are playing and
this is where uh everything
where's everything based on that's
that's super interesting
so yeah so what role do you play on the
team just curious
excuse me come again what what do you do
on the team
i'm just curious oh yeah so i'm toby i'm
the pr manager for this uh for this game
so
i'm i'm the one who's showing his beard
into the camera
and tell you how great the game is but
actually
uh actually yeah i'm taking the game i'm
traveling the world with it and i'm
trying to show it to the people and
actually that's what we did
since the kickstarter campaign showing
the game and collecting feedback and
that's what
we're also doing right now uh there's a
close beta
for iron harvest but the big
announcement if i can say it like that
from tomorrow there will be
a demo on steam so everyone can try at
least a little bit of iron harvest
before it actually releases
and that's important for us because we
are collecting feedback and try to
implement as much as possible into the
game
there's a multiplayer component where
you're fighting against your friends and
that type of thing
uh very right so uh in this rth of
course there's a big campaign
that's the part which is uh inspired by
uh warcraft 3 so with the hero unit and
the deep
deep single player campaign so there
will be
uh planned right now 21 missions for the
single player campaign but of course as
you said there's also a multiplayer
which i like
a bit more than a single player but just
me personally because
i believe that having this huge mech
fight
stomping through buildings outrunning
your opponent outsmarting your friend
is even more interesting than fighting
ai but that's just me so if you are
more into the single player part then go
ahead
he got defeated
in the tutorial with snowball
no diesel but hard eyes
you can try a skirmish battle if you
want because then you can see
more than just throwing eyes yeah and
then if you if you're
quick enough you will be even able to to
build some mix and show the people how
the
hey someone in the chat is writing snow
punk yeah snow punk
that's the tutorial exactly
that's really dope can you tell us a
little bit about the story while we
get back and go try a skirmish of course
so the story is well in this 1920 plus
universe there's
three factions in well there's more
factions but in the game there's three
factions we have
polania which is something like
alternative poland
uh it is something like alternative
russia and
saxony which is something like
alternative germany
and they are fighting each other in in
iron harvest so and the idea is that
i don't want to spoil too much about the
single player of course but the idea is
that
uh there is some kind of super weapon
somehow somehow
someone has it some everyone wants it
and
all the campaigns are actually trying to
get to this point who gets the weapon
who will take uh charge who will be the
powerful
uh source in the end of the game and uh
that's like a big overview of the
campaign
but of course uh for every campaign for
each faction we have seven missions
so you will see the different angles on
the game and the different parts of the
game
from different views and uh eventually
find out that who seems bad isn't that
bad and so on so there's
some plot twists and stuff and the
missions should be as unique as possible
cool you're gonna have to you're gonna
have to run us through this
as he starts getting things i'm going to
move in
so first of all exactly so that's the
company of hero style gameplay where you
have
there's no if you're if you think of a
command conquer something you have to
collect your tiberium here you have to
conquer those iron mines and oil pumps
and they will then over time uh generate
some
resources for you so you the big idea is
it's something like moving the front
line back and forth all the time
you have to recapture resource points
they will generate something but the
opponent can take them from you at every
moment and so on
the two units you have right now is
regular rifleman
and engineers those engineers uh with
the
uh yeah these ones exactly they have
they are building base they're pretty
much building your base so if you push
h or put on the building push the
building button
on the bottom right when you click the
engineer then you can build some
some buildings like barracks and and a
workshop
in your in your base and
as i said it's moving the front line
back and forth so on the minimap on the
left side you can see how
the opponent is slowly conquering
resource points and those
flags there and it's it's a bit like
capture
the flag so if if the opponent takes
them then there's a counter which you
can see on the top the
winning points victory points which i
personally don't like i'm for the
inhalation
fighting the opponent to the end but
yeah
winning sneaky win with victory points
is of course also possible
there's no snow so if you if no
snowballs yeah
i'm attacking these guys
yes exactly you can they saw you
probably and
or they took the oil pump and then now
they're getting something different
so on the map you have the oil pump you
have crates
in those crates there can be weapons
there can be resources
there can be uh for ex there's field gun
for example weapons lying around and you
can adapt on the battlefield while
playing the game
and the coolest thing i believe is not
only the covering system that you have
to take cover when you're attacking
someone
but when you have a mac or something
then you can walk through buildings and
just ignore all the cover because
they're
way too big and will just stomp through
that's awesome i would heavily
recommend to start building in base
because you took all your units
especially the engineers who is not good
at shooting
and you took them to yeah this house yes
the house button if you click on the
house button
then you can build for example the
barracks barracks or workshop
and put it in the base it's the thing
you
neglected in the very first moment
tobias is going in on alex uh learning
is fun
although i mean it's
it's as always it's you have to get the
basics and then
and that's why the the snowball that's
what the snowball
uh tutorial was trying to teach you that
of course
how to move on the battlefield but also
how to build your base and take care of
it
by the way my i'm trying to
right now talk to you via my cell phone
and i'm using mobile data so if anything
happens
then yeah just so you know they'll
figure it out
but it seems to work so i have my
makeshift streaming
no your stream is amazing by the way
when
we saw your camera it's like better than
like ninety percent
you know what i mean looks super
pristine
thank you cell phone manufacturer i feel
like i have
all my units and my base
so you you will learn you are learning
the hard way how about we start again
and you you use one of those units
you have there the rifleman to capture
resource points
and the other one the engineers to
immediately start to build something and
then you send out the engineers as well
so let's restart okay yeah yeah
for instance are you sure you want to
restart
yes sir so definitely you sure am
of course of course it's uh the base
building is just
well the focus is not on the base
building you need a base to be able to
build units of course
that's where you get your your max and
your soldiers
however the the uh focus on the game
will always be on the
front line of the battlefield so what
actually does
happens is that you're trying to protect
your resource points at all
at all time you are trying to push the
the enemy back and so on and what's
what's really interesting you
maybe you saw it when your units died uh
whenever you kill us
a human unit they will
drop their weapons so let's say you uh
killing
i don't know a flamethrower unit then
you can tell your engineers to pick up
the flamethrowers and they
upgrade to become flamethrower units so
potentially weak unit becomes a
potentially very strong unit however you
then lose the engineers and become flame
so this gives you a lot of independence
and and flexibility on the battlefield
which is pretty cool
so let's say the opponent is attacking
you with tanks or something
and you really need to get some cannons
quickly to get them down and to tank
cannons
then just try to pick up cannons if if
you're lucky enough to find them
anywhere somewhere
so so we have to collect
we have to push for more resources so
you can either pick up the
crates lying around you can see them on
the map there are
those white boxes those are weapon
crates or resource crates
or yeah exactly those ones
and if you it's a weapon crate so inside
there will be a weapon but there's also
oil crates and
iron crates and if you
if you uh yeah go to the resource points
then you can capture them as well
in your hq the building the only
building you have currently you can also
build a
basic unit so you could build another
engineer for example so you have three
units instead of two
what is very important for you i guess
is the retreat button so once you owns
one of your units
uh no you're a laughing but actually it
really helps you to survive because in
same as in company of heroes you cannot
afford to rebuild
so many units so you need to keep them
alive at exactly you push
perfect perfect you just push the r
button or the
button on the bottom right and they will
get a hit
they will get a hit point bonus and
they're running back to their hq where
you can repair them
or heal them okay so once they arrive at
the
at your hq they will lose this small
arrow on the head
and if you push r again you will
replenish the unit
r or the bottom top left
button so tobias when is uh when is the
release
the release uh is on the well
but this joke only works in europe
however
the game is called 19 iron harvest 1920
plus
1 920 which is the first of the
2020. okay nice only only works in
europe though so
it's in a few in a few weeks in a few
months there's the
uh iron harvest is releasing but and
that's a very important and very cool
part
from tomorrow you can get your demo on
steam for free so you can try it for
several days
so it's from june 16th to june 22nd you
can try it
give your feedback and try to stay alive
a bit longer
definitely be practicing the game is the
game is awesome it's very gorgeous
i love you know playing the beginning
part of it i'm definitely going to be
playing it
uh you can wishlist it now
exactly so go steam epic wherever
whatever shop you like
go there and you can wishlist it and try
it if you go to steam
thank you so much tobias it was it was
amazing having you
thank you very much for the invitation
was great yeah for sure all right
that was um iron harvest king art games
tobias
um the game is really fun it's cool it
takes it obviously like takes a minute
to really get into
obvious it's an rts um but the game yeah
there's a lot of strategy
um in that game which is really cool uh
it's amazing to see
like the the dynamic cover too the way
that like you go behind the
the cover and they automatically you
know take cover and stuff it's
it's it's really cool it's the kind of
thing you need like
plenty of time to kind of figure out
obviously
but but uh that's the kind of thing that
i would i would lose many
hours playing for sure okay so
up next we have say no more marius
winter
roll the trailer sir
hey you did you just start your
internship welcome intern and we're
destroyed by your co-workers
make me coffee copy these papers bed
hair day alert
your supervisor probably just stole your
lunch
thanks and the problem is you are too
shy to say something
i don't see coffee but don't worry all
you need is just
one word it's the word no
wow you work late today no well be nice
to our supervisor
clean the coffee maker
yes you learnt well
[Music]
[Music]
what is this madness
[Music]
your outfit is bad oh
you're being weird stop clapping hey
what are you doing
no i was just projecting
that was say no more this game is looks
really hilarious
um we got marius
on the line oh hey
how's it going i'm good thank you can
you hear me
yeah yeah one two one two did you did
you play one of the voices
for the game i did uh these were all
placeholder voices by me
yes oh okay because like yeah
it's the game is super hilarious by the
way um i
i kept playing it over and over again
the other day it reminds me of
um old school ps1 games which may be
like what your influence is but there's
one in particular called incredible
crisis
that i used to love and like i would
just keep playing through that game and
this
is like dead on i'm like when i saw this
game i think i saw it um
a while ago you guys were gonna show it
at the mix gdc or something like that
and and i was like oh my god gotta check
this game out um so we
finally got our hands on it alex is
gonna play through it it's hilarious
um you have to talk about like how you
came up with this
this idea thank you so much
uh yeah very cool if you look at our
inspiration document
incredible crisis is one of the games
that inspires this game
also muscle march uh on the wii
u on the wii uh was also a big
inspiration
um
muscle march is amazing you all have to
google it now
um but it's in the in it's an old wii
game i don't know if you can
play it anymore but anyway
this is more in terms of the art style
and humor what inspires this game
but the original inspiration came
so my friend nick and i we both
came up with this game and we both are
game designers at studio fitspin
and we know each other since
kindergarten so we grew up together and
played games together
that's cool and humor and
uh a couple years ago we were playing
around with unity
and making weird prototypes
and one thing that that we want to have
in video games that we
rarely get is imagine in games where you
can jump
and there's an npc and if you jump in
front of the npc just jumping around
they don't react to that and we want
games where they are like
why are you jumping around this is not
normal what are you doing
like this is these are games that we
want
and so we made a little game in an
office environment
where people talk to you and you can
only answer
um therefore things you can say
you can say yes no maybe or
interesting what do you think and and
they always
react to whatever you say
yes and then you can imagine that sorry
go go oh no go ahead go ahead i didn't
interrupt you okay
you can imagine the most fun part was to
say no to everyone
without context just always think and
and so we figured
let's just throw away all the other
things let's just
focus on no isn't that hilarious yeah
where are you where are you guys from we
are from germany we have okay
oh okay okay cool that's awesome
the uh the social interaction aspect of
it is really really interesting and i
like how you layered it
like at first you can't say anything and
then you get this motivational
and you'll see it i'm spoiling
everything but
but that's okay you get like this
motivational speaker telling you to say
no and then you get this motivational
speaker
telling you how to laugh in someone's
face like to
to startle them or mess with their mind
and just
those layers and the the interaction um
and the body language and that type of
thing is very fresh it's interesting
thank you so much yeah it's um what
also came after so when we when we knew
like let's make a fun little game about
just saying no
we also only then noticed like hey wait
a minute we both are scared of saying no
as well
like it's hard we would rather say yes
in a lot of situations than no
and we we noticed like oh this makes so
much sense that we want to make this
game
we want to be better at saying no and um
it's not like that we we we actually we
didn't have
bad internships or something like that
the office environment is just the
setting of this game
yeah but a lot about the game is just
about
you know things where you would i
i personally think for example if i get
invited to a party of a good friend
and i just don't want to go but i still
go
yes because i don't want to be because i
feel like a bad friend if i say no
yes and so this game is it's about this
i think a lot of us have that trouble
especially if you're like creative
or you know what i mean like anytime
someone asked me to do something i
want to take on the challenge personally
so it's like
i don't know it's it's interesting this
is the this is the party i know what you
mean
yeah yeah this is the part i'm talking
about though the motivational speaker
use this button say it with me no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no no no no
you can also say no in a different way
no do a cold note by pressing this
button
just walk back to your heater no press
this
no it's dark now i know you prefer the
choice
i know it's outrageous i know these days
but if you don't use it
jerks like these lunch stealers will
always
win once do you want that
no exactly no but wait
there's more before destroying shirts
with the juicy nose
confuse them like
the choice is yours
make them feel weird
[Laughter]
where i can irritate npcs yeah so just
doing a slow clap to my channel
to subscribe to my channel i like saying
no to this jerk
did you see my new lunchbook no excuse
me
what did you say
he busted a combo on his face you are
just an
intern
okay i was like the dude is like hiding
in the bushes
sometimes they're nice people and you
could get a reward if you don't say
anything
oh interesting i was just rapid firing
no everywhere
try to find a nice person this game
supports
spamming the space bar definitely
[Music]
lunch stealers
there are more lessons
what happened did you got crossed by a
jerk
but don't worry i'm here to teach you a
new kind of note
when is this game being released no and
like on what platforms
uh to do later this year okay
and i always joke about i like an iron
iron house i also have a joke for the
release i hope we can release in
november nine wow because nine in german
is
also no that is amazing
that's amazing i would go so far if you
missed that
date we we just wait a year for next
november 9 2021 that's so good or maybe
not i don't know
but but officially no we don't have a uh
exact date yet but later this year is
there
is there gonna uh be a demo out for this
for people to play
or not yet uh yeah there's also a demo
on
steam okay and on the end the steam game
so so oh cool yeah shout out to valve
for uh working with the gorilla
collective and all and all the devs for
uh
to get our games up
i don't know why why you're saying the
uh dialogue is temp
i i would i would keep this it's solid
and this is coming from like a vo expert
this is a sound studio thank you so much
i actually will voice a lot of
characters but
we uh we casted a couple
more actors so that's
there's more variety the dialogue is
hilarious
and so did you write all the dialogue i
wrote it together with brandon gibbons
so we so we basically this was also
um
uh like this was one of the technical
challenges like having
uh building the tools for us to put in
a lot of the creative choices and yeah
we
basically in each level we just write in
a big sheet we just write to the jokes
top to bottom and there was there was it
was just
you just write them and then they are in
and that's awesome
yeah it was a really fun experience
writing the jokes because it was
a lot like a lot of elements in this
game it's just like
here's a funny thought i write it down
and it's done
there are a lot of things where we don't
think too much about them
and if they make us laugh then we keep
keeping the silly stuff
because there's a lot of encounters you
have in this game this is just the first
of eight levels
well we are not going to spoil the end
of this this uh
demo for everybody it's
so this this game is so amazing um
everybody wish list it
um and check out the game
soon nine
[Laughter]
but yeah uh thank you so much maris um
where can they follow the game and where
can they check everything out
uh we now have a twitter account it's
today it's
at say normal underscore game
and um and also our webpages say no more
dot re and yeah this is the the
this is where you get the news and all
the news
news yeah cool i didn't practice
[Laughter]
[Music]
the game is like really refreshing you
know to see something like
brand spanking new and different keep
making these type of games
i think we need to celebrate this kind
of ingenuity and
an interesting uh kind of design so yeah
very cool thanks for coming on thanks
for having me
all right say no more
say no more justin okay i definitely
won't um
the game that game is is freaking
hilarious um
it's definitely up my alley what we have
next is tanya short with boyfriend
dungeon
uh let's roll the trailer please
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
that was the amazing trailer for
boyfriend dungeon the highly anticipated
game from kipfox games
and we have tanya chilling out with us
hello how's it going it's all right you
know it's a monday
and there's super cool indie games being
shown by gorilla
and steam so it's a good day yeah yeah
it's a great day thanks uh for hopping
on
um the game looks amazing by the way i
know a lot of people are anticipating it
and we're going yeah we've gotten a lot
of wishlists a lot of attention
and it's a shame we can't you know go to
conventions anymore but i'm glad that
there's events like this so people can
still
find out about it and and see what they
like and and this demo
has never been shown outside of a
convention floor
so this is pretty nerve-wracking but
also exciting
yeah oh that totally makes sense i
remember like when we were sho
we're working with you guys to showcase
it last year we were trying to get you
on the stream and you're like
not yet not yet not yet you know but so
this is it's cool to actually be able to
uh to showcase it so tell us a little
bit about the game
so it's a dating sim slash dungeon
crawler
and you alternate between the two parts
of the game
you spend a lot of time in the dungeon
and in that dungeon you find treasure
and you fight monsters and you find new
weapons
and then those weapons become beautiful
people
and if you want to get more skilled with
that weapon and find new abilities then
you got to date them
you could also just be friends platonic
weapon relationships are possible
but yeah you choose who you want to hang
out with and then you choose who you
want to fight with
and meanwhile there's uh you know other
people you can you can text message here
go shopping um live your best life in
verona beach
california nice
what what was the uh inspiration behind
behind your game
coming up with this it's a really
interesting idea
thank you yeah i mean i grew up playing
dungeon crawlers and rpgs and dating
sims
and there's a few other games that have
you know decent combat and decent dating
but
i never felt like i was able to date all
the people i wanted to
and i don't know i also felt like
sometimes they were a little bit too
serious
so i guess i wanted something a little
bit lighter
and i wanted to be able to date all the
different kinds of people
and uh i was surprised a few years ago
that you know that that game still
didn't really exist
so we had to make it totally makes sense
it kind of reminds me like when i first
played it or saw it it kind of
initially reminded me of persona the old
like the
one of the first two personas and then
um also it reminded me just the idea of
the weapons having kind of their own
personality
uh was disgaea just a little bit but
it's it's interesting that you have that
aspect that each one of these
characters is a weapon you know
so you can see he's picking uh an
upgrade uh ability there
and um you can go back and change that
later in the in the full game there's a
gym where you can you can change up your
your combos that you've picked um but
yeah every level
of love frank up you'll you'll get
either a new ability or a choice of two
abilities
yeah we took okay you're a swinger then
good job yeah
um or maybe that just means
um yeah we've been freaking from a lot
of different places
i feel like we came up with something
that's pretty unique um
but yeah i love each of the weapons
because they're all so different
how many weapons are there in the game
so
and the kickstarter that we ran a couple
years ago we announced
nine it looks like we're probably going
to
launch with seven and then have two uh
come out as a free dlc afterwards
okay cool at least free for kickstarter
backers i we haven't decided if we're
gonna
charge after that makes sense
i can imagine that your the creativity
on your team goes wild trying to come up
with new weapon you know what i mean oh
my god there's this one that we want to
create and there's that one that kind of
thing
yeah there's so many different kinds of
weapons out there and different
i was really surprised to find that so
many people had a fondness for a certain
kind of weapon um
and you know seven isn't you know
uh borderlands or anything number of
weapons
but hopefully there's a good range of
different kinds of personalities and
different kinds of swords and uh
and then there will be something for
everybody i hope
so yeah there's four four guys and
two women and and two non-binary people
oh okay interesting and then a cat
oh really that's i did not see that one
yeah he's uh these little brass knuckles
nice transformation sequence it's so
sick
this is tower he's uh going back to his
human form
to flirt better
so tell us a little bit about the
dungeon crawling sequence yeah
so after this date i assume you'll
you'll go into the dungeon um
it's randomly generated and the first m
the first dungeon that you unlock is a
mall
dungeon um and the dungeons are
manifestations of your own fears and
insecurities so it's sort of like a form
of therapy that's a little bit more
violent
and so you're gonna i'm not gonna spoil
what all the symbolism is of the
different enemies in the mall dungeon
but then later
a nightclub dungeon is also unlocked um
and you'll get to know this whole town
over the course of the game
but the yeah so far we're planning
two full dungeons and then also
a mini dungeon for the boss fight and
we'll see if there's more for the the
dlc as well but there's
12 floors you have to fight through and
if you make it through
four floors you'll earn an elevator
you'll unlock an elevator so you can you
can skip through the first four floors
okay cool and you said they're randomly
generated
every time randomly generated yeah and
there's
so there's these uh different enemies
you can fight and
you're going to level up both in terms
of love with your weapon that you're
wielding
but also you yourself will gain
experience points and level of your
wielder level so that's your like
overall strength
and there's also little hangouts you can
find in the dunge so
little little places you can go and
spend a few seconds a few extra minutes
together it's like unwind
and enjoy use your boba son
use your boba yeah heal yourself with
your
bubble tea although we have science you
can change the if you you know if you're
not a big fan of bubble tea you can
always get
uh coffee boyfriend dungeon supports
different kinds of beverage
nice so can you
unveil like what like one of the
metaphors behind the
um enemies i know you don't want to
spoil too much but you're hitting cell
phones and
tvs well i'll say that in the tutorial
um you're sort of guided through this
with
stock as stuff sort of teaches you the
the basics of sword fighting and also
like what the dungeon is about and he
says there's a few possibilities he
thinks maybe it has to do
with you know feeling a little bit cold
and stagnant
like what what why are they all sort of
older technologies
and so it's about a fear of stagnation
is it about a fear of
getting outdated um is it a fear of
technology you know you'll find out as
you go but um
the main the main focus of the game is
the relationship with your weapons but
there is sort of this undercurrent
of uh of you as a player being this this
person who's never dated anyone before
and you move to a new town and you go to
the dungeon and you find monsters and
meet all these beautiful people
and uh hopefully you're confronting your
fears a little bit too
yeah you can see if you if you if you
vary up your
light attacks and heavy attacks you'll
get different combos
and since you unlocked your level 2 now
you're going to have
bleeding effects on the enemies and so
as you level up with tawar you'll get
better
and better options for how to how to
control your bleeding
effects and get more damage over time
going on more different kinds of enemies
but that's towards specialty okay
it looks like there's a treasure chest
but it depends if you want to if you
want to go deeper
go get that treasure chest i'm looking
at your mini map in the upper right
oh upper right oh is it the staircase
is that what that is the staircase is
how you how you uh move further down
oh but there's a trophy yeah right down
this way
okay we don't have to let's let's go i
have to collect all the treasure
you need to they tend to be recipes
that you can oh this uh ambush
um but yeah you'll find recipes so you
can craft different
um artimers or different um hats
or different outfits or gifts
you can you can craft gifts to give to
your
your dates when you're out with them all
the time
so when you go back home you're able to
craft different things with your recipes
or
is it like uh right in a dungeon during
combat
no i don't know you get um materials and
recipes
um plastic is a new ingredient you've
just found
um but yeah i know when you go back home
you can craft stuff that then take out
with you
and although it's not in the demo and
they definitely can't craft but it's
it's working in the in the real game i
promise
i assure you it's working what are you
uh launching on
we have announced that we're launching
on pc and mac
and switch cool nice
we don't have a release date i'm sorry
it's not
totally get that totally understand
it's really pandemic and everything is
making it difficult i think we had
wanted to announce a date by now but uh
well we're doing our best we want the
game to be really good that's that's
what we really want we want all of this
to be as
good as it can be before it uh
gets out into everyone's hands
kickstarter backers have really high
expectations
to make sense you guys killed it with
your kickstarter which is awesome
thank you thank you yeah it was really
fun we met a lot of really great people
we our discord blew up we have a lot of
really
lovely folks of all different kinds that
are
cheering us on so we're not afraid
of launching we just really want it to
be good because you know at this point
we've spent
over four years on it and it'd be a
shame to spend four years and then
release something
that you didn't think was great you know
yeah for sure
same boat i mean no matter what you
always have things you're going to want
to change after launch but
yeah yeah how it's so are you in
montreal
yeah yeah we're montreal studio how was
your team
i was going to say how's your team
handling working um
remotely pretty good pretty good
we um we actually already had one work
from home day every week
anyway um so we had the basics set up
of course i think people are getting a
little bit lonely and restless now that
it's been a while don't forget to drink
your tea
there we go yeah um
yeah it feels feels better oh you found
a vending machine
i wonder what that's about get some more
five bucks in there some randos oh
what's gonna happen
mysterious
secret you found a secret that's that's
pretty dope
these monsters are just hanging out what
are they doing
so how do we find out more about the
game is is a demo coming out
soon are you going to lose
okay we're probably going to wait on the
demo for a little bit longer
uh to release it to everybody but you
can wishlist the game on steam you can
subscribe to our newsletter if you go to
boyfrienddungeon.com
you can read more about it you can join
our discord you can tweet at us
we have all the boyfriend details for
you
and the community is really welcoming so
if you just want to make some
new friends maybe join and chat
boyfriend engine with us anytime
thanks so much for joining us it's
awesome to thanks for having me get the
game in our hands and play it
nope boyfriend dungeon
thanks sonia bye that's tonya from
kickfox games boyfriend dungeon highly
anticipated their community is crazy
it's it's pretty awesome
um up next wait let's let's shout out
our
our sponsors and our partners uh they've
been amazing
helping us to make this happen idea xbox
razer
wilmer sounds for for helping put this
together we also want to shout out to
our
media sponsors ign gamespot
twitch of course um the id at xbox folks
are working with us on mixer it couldn't
have been possible without you guys this
is
all an independent collective of
developers
and publishers and they really believed
in what we were doing for the movement
um also you can contribute to
the charities that we have during these
crazy times
um unicef in double acp and the game
heads
uh through our charity link below it's
definitely will help some folks out
um but up next yes we have 30xxx the
sequel to 20
x x run the tresailer
[Music]
[Music]
that was 30 xx the sequel to 20xx or
2000 in xx um
here we got chris king we're gonna plate
the game
highly anticipated how's it going
good good uh yeah thanks for sharing the
game when i saw that you guys like
entered 30xx i was like oh my god
because
like 20xxx like uh i mean for me
personally as a you know a developer and
you know loving capcom games that kind
of thing it kind of came out of nowhere
i was like what is this
at first i was like this is a mega man
clone and then i was like looking at how
you guys were developing it and evolving
the game and it was like what this is
you know obviously it pays homage but
it's a different type of experience and
to see
that you guys like made that it was
successful
and then you guys are making this one
and the art looks gorgeous
um can you tell us a little bit about
the evolution
um of what you've done in the genre with
this game
yeah of course uh so with the first game
you know we're obviously we're super
happy with how well
20xxx uh did for us you know it was our
first commercial game uh none of us had
made games before it was the first time
we'd really come to this and so
you know first time game developments
really spicy business right uh so so
being able to have the studio still be
around at this point is
super exciting to us but even after
having spent five years making 20xx
uh we still had so much more that we
wanted to do with the formula
uh there's still so much room to improve
so much room for the game to grow
and we knew that getting it to this
really like high fidelity really crisp
punchy pixel art style was where we we
always kind of wanted to take the title
in the first place
uh and so we knew there was so much more
we wanted to do on pretty much
every every side of the game uh so it
just made sense to
go ahead and make a full sequel nice
nice
uh i think you should can we play
multiplayer is it yeah yeah
okay absolutely we'll wait until we go
if he dies
then which will certainly happen i will
die
for sure all right
so can you tell us a little bit about
like i don't know i i'm obviously
interested in the process
but tell us about the game sure so 30xxx
uh is kind of like
co-op roguelike mega man x so it it
controls a lot like the uh the classic
action platformers of
the 90s era except with you know far
crisper controls that are possible
during that area because we uh
we have much better like pc refresh
rates now right so we're able to process
your inputs way faster so it's going to
be crisper than was ever possible back
then
uh but so it's it's kind of like that
action platformer style but everything's
randomly generated every time you play
through it so the level sets you're
going to see are going to be different
you're going to get powers in a
different order uh so you can make that
jump
yeah and your dash by default uh should
be on either right bumper or right
trigger depending on your settings but
maybe don't practice that right here
yeah this is a fun piece to get right at
the beginning of the demo
maybe we'll see co-op after all so hit
those hit those little crystals as you
go they spawn little platforms
oh that was fast
no that was very obviously on purpose
you're gonna have to run through this
because you know playing this
style of game and then asking questions
is a rough
business it's tough yeah you really you
really gotta focus so you're moving
around uh you're dashing
uh if you jump while you dash you're
gonna do like a long jump you can cross
much bigger gaps with wait so you
dash this is interesting playing
now i was talking mad stuff and now i
can't even
get up oh my god
yeah you got to go a little higher than
you got it
okay trial by fire everything's great
you notice the camera zooms out a bunch
in co-op
yeah that's awesome it's cool to play
this it's like when i was a
i died but um as a kid you always wanted
to play these style of games
with somebody so having that component
is really
that's exactly where we were right uh we
yeah when we we first started making
20xx we really just wanted
the ability to have some kind of
cooperative play in these kinds of games
because we always wanted them growing up
right
you know growing up you had to share the
controller yeah you know your brother
wants to play and
you have a really hard lesson very
quickly about having difficult chunks at
the beginning of a demo
that's streamed in front of a bunch of
people yeah no it's good
the game is challenging which is which
is great
it is challenging this is a very uh
early pre-alpha for
us uh this is super super early stuff uh
you know we've obviously spent time
polishing the demo
uh but you know since it's a roguelike
since we're gonna throw random level
pieces at you
uh every so often we're gonna have
pieces that are maybe a little more
difficult than we intend to be
really early at the beginning of a demo
show up like this looks much more
reasonable no
required precise wall jumps just
probably where you ought to be on level
one of a demo
i have some work to do after this
but i learned how to jump you know do a
uh vertical wall jump which is great now
i'm going to use that tool
you know you know ideally though i teach
you to do that without a fire that's
going to kill you
right there and just wrecking oh he's
dead it did
okay so because it's like anytime you
fall in lava or touch a spike or
anything like that we're just gonna do a
little bit of damage to you and set you
back instead of like
straight up killing you uh there are
optional difficulty toggles of course
that let you turn on
auto kill spikes but like pretty
unfriendly for a game like this where
you expect you to get through on one
shot
let's go there you go
so how's the game laid out as far as
progression
that is an awesome question uh so in
20xx there are four basic level themes
you play through twice
every time you play through a run of the
game but a run of the game is eight
levels there are themes
eight main sequence stages that are in a
semi-random order the player has some
level of control over the order in which
they tackle the stages but not
complete control so like in a mega man
game you finish a stage and there are
seven stages left right you can pick
whatever one yeah you're getting chased
run
ah match by the wolf spikeys
and maybe don't touch the fire
so this is what you're noticing here and
this is this is critical to our to our
process here right is that you're making
progress each of these runs has gotten
further than the last
yes we're getting better you are you are
you absolutely are
we're learning machines again 30xxx
each boss each main sequence stage has
his own entire
unique set this time oh it's this piece
again
oh look at that see this i learned it
not all right close love to see it oh
it's this
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna start there it
is
i mean it's got it okay uh so this
should also still work in the demo but
if
ace holds b for a couple seconds you
should be able to like teleport up to
your teammate
oh oh what just a co-op feature
and then let go oh nice yeah
oh schnooks old carryover feature from
20xxx it's important
you know one of the things one of the
things here is that we want to make sure
that when you're playing 30xxx with a
friend
uh that it's always uh it's always a fun
experience regardless of
potential like skill disparities between
yeah i was thinking
one of the things that can get really
tough uh especially i think the
the onus for us adding that was
definitely uh at one and one packs with
20xx years ago
uh we had it was like a young father uh
telling us that he
his kid absolutely loves the game has so
much fun of it loves the characters
uh but just really struggles with some
of the the platforming segments
yeah and having the you know the child
able to like teleport up meet the
meet the parent uh made their experience
a million times better so we spent a
little time shot that and got it
and of course uh we want to make sure
that all of the all of the lessons we
learned while we were making 20xx
carry over to 30xxx you know we don't
want to backslide it in here
yeah for sure yeah i was going to say i
had seen this piece
i was going to say for for if you're
playing with kids that's
that's really important that's really
awesome that you you you did that
yeah we want the game you know so
obviously at the top end like with this
this kind of game hey revive capsule
it's good to know those work in the demo
free testing yeah oh man
uh yeah we gotta we gotta make sure that
uh while the game needs to be
properly challenging at the top end like
if you're if you grew up with these kind
of games you
you want the super spicy intense like
perfect platforming
uh that the sort of topper like harder
top end of these games really can afford
hey box
hey some health and some money i got
nice can he teleport
down to me yeah so so that we'll don't
do it on a fire
yeah try it good on that yeah there you
go so it should work pretty
much anywhere oh okay cool
all right how big is it come up on this
chase section again oh okay yeah so we
know that we don't want to get hit by
the
the wolf spikes folks don't want to get
hit by a spike spikes
oh look at that look at my skills on
nothing
i thought my little further a little
further my skills weren't picking up
level last time
[Music]
how big is your team uh there are it
really
really depends on how you measure uh
there are eight or so of us
working on 30xx right now all of which
in different capacities you know if you
if you're adding up everybody's like
full-time contributions it's probably
more like six uh you know it's uh it's
myself doing uh
tech creative design uh we've got two
lovely artists uh one doing uh
characters in sprite work that's
caller kataki uh if you recognize this
kind of sprite style from either like
rogue legacy or chasm or duelist the
same guy
oh yeah cool the tiles and the backdrops
and all that stuff is uh
fabian destromski uh german environment
artists they've both been lovely
brandon ellis our composer in georgia
with all the uh the sweet tunes that
you've gotta have
yeah uh nice uh and we've got a
like this sorry i'm getting a little too
into the weeds about individual team
members but nobody's lovely they're
about it it's interesting
that's cool
yeah it's about twice the size of
20xxx's team it's been solid
uh so you can teleport up yeah i'm gonna
teleport over there
did you get deaded all right one more
teleporter he teleported up while you
were in midair and then yeah
i was wondering if that was possible or
uh
but yes it is so you gotta be careful
when you teleport
nice i like the rogue um
aspects just the variety and not knowing
exactly what your face but the skills
are maintained that's really interesting
exactly that's that's like that's the
core of the design right there right
so we love these precise adaptations we
love
seeing a situation thinking what's in my
toolkit that lets me respond to this
and then adapt it and then mastering the
game right
we we don't love mega man 2's like heat
man disappearing blocks where the only
way to get it is to
like die a bunch of times by falling
into the pit with no
no indication of where the blocks are
appearing
so we throw different pieces of you
every time obviously it's a very
early roguelike like we're still very
early in the process we're not even in
early access yet we've got a ways to go
there
uh but
uh there's a pretty decent amount of
level generation
that's awesome so when are you releasing
do you have a do you have a date
that is a great question uh we don't
have a firm date yet
uh we're definitely going to do early
access so early access for
20xxx anybody watching either player
20xxx or saw during early access
uh you know that we were in early access
for two and a half years
about really a long time uh the only
reason we're still here the only reason
the studio is still here the only reason
we get to make a new game
is because our incredible early access
community on 20xx
uh gave us the the feedback and the the
resources and
the pushes we need uh to make the game
great uh so we'd be
really foolish to not do early access
this time around uh so early access is
definitely coming
uh probably sometime between this fall
and next spring
we've been telling people it's like a 70
chance that it's somewhere in that
window
but it depends on a lot of stuff and
then 1.0 is sometime after that
you know we can't hit a 1.0 release date
until we know exactly how much stuff
we've got to get done in early access
that's that totally makes sense the game
is gorgeous it's really really
fun to play and you're you're releasing
on um what what platforms
initially i know you said early access
so that'll be yeah steam right
so so pc pc first for sure uh our
official line right now is
pc and consoles uh we don't know which
consoles yet we're still working on that
totally makes sense can you wish list
now you can wish list now and as of
right this moment right here uh right
now you can actually uh
play our steam festival demo this demo
early
now right now actually right now uh you
can click it and have fun
uh you can google 30xxx steam it'll
probably pop up pretty easily there
unlike 20xx we have a little bit better
seo this time around thankfully
and of course you can wishlist it yeah
please yeah wishlist the game play the
game the game is really cool
um thanks so much for hopping on where
can we find you and the game
any last shout outs uh yeah i mean i'm
just i'm so i'm so proud of the team
we've put together uh thank you guys so
much uh for
for helping us get this game to where it
is now and i want to shout out
the community for having been so
supportive of us while we've been
building it uh without you guys we we
are nothing and we have nothing and
we're so happy that you're here for the
journey
dope thanks you so much thanks for
watching of course thank you guys
take care all right that was 30 xx
it's coming along so great make sure to
uh
wish list it and check out their steam
page
next up we have west of dead
uh adam is going to be joining us let's
roll to the trailer
purgatory wyoming
1888
a shifting land shaped by the souls of
the dead
the good ones head east toward the light
the bad ones sometimes
they stick around when they ain't
supposed to
that's where i come in
to change their minds
i got a job to do
[Music]
you better
some say a coward dies a thousand deaths
and a hero only dies once
i says a hero or someone
who keeps coming back
[Music]
that was the amazing trailer of um
west of dead we got adam on the line
what is popping adam how are you doing
good very good thank you excited i like
your your poster
logan is sick oh yeah i've got loads of
loads of rubbish up here loads of dark
stuff
yeah so um yeah we we've been playing
the game like congratulations
it it looks amazing it's so awesome to
have
you know um the actors you have involved
with it
um it's yeah the game is gorgeous
yeah how did that even even come about
well you know i'd like to say it was
completely by design
100 skill it was our plan the whole time
but
really it only happened when we teamed
up with raw fury
and they saw something a lot
bigger in the game than we had the
confidence being british
we're low on confidence um so
i got more confidence in the title and
what we were making than we presumed to
have
so they said oh you guys you know who
would be your ideal
you know actor to be the narrator in
this game
and we were like well you know from
perlman
then we'll never get him and and they
did so
we we thought they were joking most of
the time and then they said no
we really we really have got him and uh
yeah so that was a bit of a dream come
true for us to be honest
that's cool yeah shout out to raw fury
they've been amazing with the
um working with us on the gorilla
collective and then showcasing your game
um some exclusive stuff was was pretty
awesome i mean we've been following this
game for
for a while um and yeah having ron
perlman
definitely you know adds notoriety but
also
to the theme you know because it sounds
so rich yeah
yeah you know definitely he was yeah
by far the top of our list so yeah we're
very very lucky
so tell us about the game and like how
you came up with the whole idea your
team came up with the idea
and the design yeah no no problem at all
so
um i mean what we usually like to say is
that
a person had a very clear idea on
everything that isn't how this happened
at all it was very much a bucket list of
things that we love
like so we love comic books and we love
different flavors of shooters
and uh we love like horror games as well
and we had all these different ideas
about things that might be really fun
and we decided to try and put it all in
one package
and see what happens uh luckily
for us it seems to come together into
something that has
its own sort of voice which i literally
quite proud of
so tell us about a little bit about the
mechanics
as he's yeah as you can see we've
yeah i mean you can see straight away
that we were you know trying to
meld two different uh shooter genres
that
very rarely have anything to do with one
another so we're big fans of 26 shooters
but we also wanted to see what could
happen if we bought
cover mechanics into the center of the
twin stick experience
and that was quite noble for us we
hadn't seen that done
or combined in that way before and that
means quite a lot of
prototyping and testing as as always to
try and figure that out
but we're trying to get this clear thing
sort of like a
western style gun fight where you crouch
behind cover
count your bullets dash out do some
damage and then get back into cover
again
and nearly every system in the game is
to try and
do one of two things uh the badges are
either trying to
get you out of cover or if you're out of
cover they're trying to get you back
into cover again
so it's got a very quite unique staccato
pace to it
and the the um the cover is breakable
and
explodes and stuff like that as you go
along so they're trying to destroy the
cover
while you're trying to kill them
absolutely yeah so
with the classic western shootouts
you'll dive behind cover
reload your weapons and you have a boost
to
how quickly you can reload when you're
behind cover so there's good reasons to
get in there
and but cover doesn't last forever the
great thing about it though is you can
shoot from cover with complete impunity
if you're behind cover
even if you're shooting the cover is
going to take the damage not you
but it doesn't last nice that's really
cool it does
definitely look like a living breathing
comic book
which is oh thank you very much exactly
what we're hoping to hear
the k you know all the characters have a
lot of like interesting design he's got
the red cape and kind of like the ghost
rider
flame but then he has this like i'm an
art dude so like
you know looking at that this is the
first thing i kind of key into but he
has like the
the slash across his skull which is
really
like makes him stand out you know i
could definitely see figures and stuff
made from this character oh yeah
definitely i think a lot of our
love for different comic books strong
through a lot of the designs especially
when it came to like the main characters
and
uh that appear in the title for sure
very good you're playing well oh as you
can see um we've had to use quite a lot
of interesting things with the different
weapons you have as well so
shotguns have a very short range
compared to rifles
and there's about four different flavors
of weapons there's
rifles shotguns pistols and revolvers
and each of these squeeze the player
into a different corner of the gameplay
so shotguns are a great close-up and
have a wide arc
but you've really got to get out from
cover to get close enough to use them
most of the time
unless you're willing to sit and wait
for something to come to you
so can you tell us about the uh or tell
the world about the
story and the narrative behind what's
going on yeah
yeah yeah i'd love to absolutely love
you so we are
doing a quite a riff of the uh kind of
like a stranger
in town um sort of classic
um western style story you don't know
who you are um
you don't know who you were um but you
know that there is
a new place that you need to clean up
and um
but this place different from other
westerns is
some is setting the afterlife but not
your
classical kind of christian style after
life that we thought
it's its own place it's got its own kind
of law
and this is a place which is shaped by
the memories and fears of the souls that
are stuck
there and normally stop the souls will
pass through everything is fine
and they face some kind of judgment the
good ones headies and the bad ones are
saint west
but for some reason purgatory is stuck
people aren't leaving when they should
and that's because something's going
wrong
which is what you're there to sort out
oh nice shot sounds like a money shot
for sure
i can't wait to see some of the bosses i
bet you there the design is
outstanding oh that yeah that we've had
a lot of fun designing a lot of these
enemies
i mean the other thing about this story
is with the structure is a kind of a
road like structure so
you never know what's around the nest
corner we want that to
really we really want to make the
players a skill build up
and keep facing them with new surprises
each run
but trying to mesh that with a clear
story is
a bit of a challenge actually so we had
to start
we had to start thinking about the story
not as a straight line but as a spiral
that goes back around and back around to
the same point
and what can we tell the player in these
known little areas of the game and which
is usually in between levels
it turns out so there's a little class
of characters who will tell you
a bit about themselves a bit about your
past as well as
recurring antagonists that you'll come
across as bosses
as the game moves forward so is it so
the
the um the enemy distribution is
randomized
and are like the is the cover randomized
or the levels randomized or just
mostly the enemy distribution it is so
the
every room um so you're speaking to the
coder here so stand back i'm going to
start going into detail
go in don't win so every room that
you're in
has been thought of as like a dozen
different flavors or
encounters so there's lots of different
places where it
might be a good place to have cover it
might be a good place to have
a column in the way and
then also the rooms are all combined in
different orders
the contents of the room is different
every time
and also we have basically a like a
magic bucket of
baddies that we we put in a certain
number of
points and he said give us give us 30
points of baddies
and it will shake itself and then pour
out a few baddies for each room
so that allows us to have some degree
on the exact number enemies that you
might have
but we kind of make recipes of enemies
so we always want to have one of these
guys
as a minimum but we can never have more
than two of these types of baddies
so when we throw that through a computer
we end up with
what we hope is a best of both side best
of both
where there are rules and structure to
the kind of encounters that you have
it will never be a mob or purely melee
guys
at the same time it won't be the same
every time either you'll be different
for every single room every single round
that's cool guys
i was wondering about health because i
was like it looked like i went to a room
where i was like sort of
was i saving my progress there what was
the that's right yeah so if
if the if the skull uh flashes in the
bottom right corner
yeah so that ring those are save points
so you can
recover your rung back from there um if
you haven't died so if you want it you
have to go make a cup of tea
or coffee you can come back and continue
your run from there
um so it's got an in-game save so you
can
runs can get pretty long so if you feel
like i'm an hour ring but i don't want
to lose my run you can stop
and come back later on um and also
it's a road light so there are extra
abilities that you can permanently
unlock
for example a health flask which lets
you have one
heel per run followed by a better health
flask with two heels per run
or rather two heels per level and these
things
start to give you just a slight leg up
at the start of the runs so
it depends on how confident you are you
can
if you really need to grind it a little
bit just give yourself a bit of a leg up
or if you're feeling you know super on
it from the start you can
get further without having to die too
many times
wes this game is west of dead looks dope
man it's so good
yeah it's really cool people are going
to definitely enjoy this so
right now can you wishlist on steam and
i saw that the
it's you can uh play the gym on xbox
right
yes you can so you can play the demo on
xbox and steam
it is currently on an open beta and
i think i'm meant to say this i can't
see any notifications popping up so if
you play the um
the open visa i think you can get a
discount on the launch
which is on thursday
thursday is the launch so everybody pick
that up
make sure to um to definitely you know
check out this game it's really awesome
thanks for joining us
how could we find out more about you and
your team and and
oh anything else you want to talk about
yeah please so we are upstream arcade
um google us um we should be we should
be there i could
i won't do that right now yeah google us
find out a bit more about us
and uh this is the west of dead um and
yeah
the team got a very small team only four
people
oh really the central team so we're
you know very excited nervous and hope
that everyone has a lot of fun playing
it
cool thanks so much uh thanks adam that
was uh west of dead
the game is cool shout out to to raw
fury again for
hooking them up with with ron perlman
and and just being amazing publishers
um next up we have system
shock check out the trailer
[Music]
[Music]
time
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so that was the systems shock trailer
which
we um showed yesterday on the gorilla
collective for the first time the game
looks really amazing
here we have stephen kick ceo of night
dive
games and it's great to have you here to
talk with us the ceo of night dive
how's it going good good thank you so
much for the opportunity i'm glad to uh
glad to be here to talk shock time
i thought you say talk shot um
no it's it's so awesome to have you i'm
a big fan of like a lot of the stuff
that you've
you've remastered and the games that
you've worked on previously
i think i was talking about like maybe a
week before we knew you were
you know gonna be on the live stream
about like turok and
and sin gold and and just a lot of the
games that you've
you guys worked on which were a big part
of my childhood
you know with my like voodoo card you
know voodoo 2 car
you know vfx chip card and my like
janky celeron processor but playing all
those games back in the day
they're like the first 3d game so it's
cool that you were able to
to jump in and and have your team work
on system shock
congratulations on the success that
you've had so far
yeah thank you very much and uh you
could say
kind of the core philosophy of night
dive has been to go out and find those
games that you and i both played as kids
and
and be able to resurrect them so that
not only we can enjoy them but
uh new generations can enjoy them as
well
yeah that's that's awesome so can you
tell us a little bit about like how
system shock like came to be um
this version of it this version of it
okay so
um night dive started uh
at the beginning of 2012 with the
re-release of system shock 2 which
up to that point had not seen a digital
re-release of any kind
and the success of that is kind of what
uh catapulted night dive into the
business of going out and finding
other ip and other games to to resurrect
oh cool and um system shock was just one
of those games that once we had the
rights to it we knew
was kind of owed a remaster or a
re-release of some kind because
as good as it was back in 1994
it was very obtuse the control scheme
was kind of notoriously difficult
uh to master um 3d was still kind of
on the on the cusp of of
widespread use in the industry it was up
against games like doom
uh so it just didn't really have the
chance to to really breathe and to
show what it had to offer and so we
thought it was just the perfect
game to breathe new life into
and so we've completely redone the game
from the ground up
in unreal engine 4 um
it started off as a kickstarter project
back in 2016 and it's grown and evolved
to what we're playing now
what were some of the things that you
did to make it more accessible
uh this one's gonna seem fairly obvious
but uh even adding something as simple
as mouse look
uh does wonders for it the original
didn't have that
uh it's kind of hard to explain but you
had to kind of click and drag the screen
around
the viewport and uh we've since added
mouth look into the original but
this game is going to play very much
like a
contemporary first person shooter
we're going to add in tutorial tool tips
to help people along the way so they
understand what
you know these implants do that you're
installing now
uh combat and everything is going to be
familiar to anybody who's played a
you know first-person shooter in the
last uh 15-20 years
yeah this is a this is a game that
definitely benefits from
a uh an upgrade a uh modernization
and uh this is really beautiful uh
in terms of you know how it looks not
only but uh gameplay too
and i was noticing that like as you get
close to things they have they still
have this sort of pixelated let me go to
something
like this like this pixelated art style
which is
very reminiscent um of the
but then as you get farther away you
know you have that incredible
lighting and and uh those reflections
and stuff it looks awesome
yeah thank you that this art style is
something that we
have taken a lot of pride in uh because
we did want to pay homage to the
original
in some way um artistically
and one of the first things we did was
um
actually brought on the original concept
artist and
main artist from the original system
shots
to re-envision um all the environments
all the enemies all the weapons pretty
much everything
and so we've not only got to see his
evolution as an artist over the last 20
years
but also
exactly how system shock would look
today
if it were updated so this is as true to
a
a new realization of that as as humanly
possible
yeah you want to pick up that ammo
getting really sucked into this game
yeah i just kind of want to let
the ambiance roll through you know what
i mean i mean i don't mind watching it's
always a thrill to see somebody play it
for the first time
yeah you know it was so hard to play uh
back in the day i wasn't primarily a pc
gamer
i had a mac but you know it was one of
those games where you're like
because deus ex for me was one of my
favorite games
and um and and this is obviously kind of
a precursor to that
um and uh it's one of those games that
you wish you
could have played more so it's so
awesome that you've done this you've
gone to this effort
and this is funny too it's like you've
there there was no way to do something
like this
uh you know with the the textures that
they had where it's like okay
enter the keypad here
um yeah you know what i just noticed is
you're playing with a gamepad
and it might be a lot more difficult
um just because we haven't really
implemented
um full controller support yet like it
seems like you're getting by
yeah um but when the game does come out
on you know playstation and xbox and
games that are going to use that control
scheme it's going to be a lot more uh
fluid yeah it feels good on the gamepad
i mean it does it now
definitely understand that
and these are this is the original audio
right from
level 2 yes so
right now all the audio logs and
showdance
audio is from the original game and
that's purely temporary
okay uh we figured hey we've got the
audio let's
let's use that um to stub in
while we're developing and then as we
kind of
um near the end of development we'll go
ahead and re-record all this audio with
professional voiced actors and new lines
right all levels i was i was wondering
that
and it's it's it is a nice touch though
it you know maybe as a something of
you know an option i don't know if
you're gonna
keep it but it it's it is fun to hear
the old stuff
i remember playing this and those dudes
creeped me the hell out yeah
it's still a creepy cell you uh may want
to use a meta patch pretty soon
oh yeah um okay how do i do that
this is where this is the uh it's the
red one all the way to the left oh okay
this one yeah and how do i
click it i wish i could tell you on the
keyboard it's uh you just hit
one on the keyboard one okay hold on
i've got a keyboard wait i have to get
out of this do i oh yeah there you go
you could do
you could use use like that yeah hold on
there you go
ah wow nice see the gamepad is
is working yeah if i just make it happen
if i was good at it
yeah there we go okay um
oh yeah and i can select my gun so the
demo is out now
um which is awesome that everybody can
play it and you can wishlist it now on
steam correct
that's right yeah nice and um yeah it's
out on
gog and steam currently okay cool
and you're when you release are you
going to release multi-platform
simultaneously or
are you going to release pc first
um a simultaneous release is the plan so
we'll be hitting
playstation uh xbox and pc all at the
same time
uh but we're still a little ways off
from that so we'll see
but that is the plan that makes sense
you don't have a release yet or do you
have one
it's to be decided makes sense
when it's done i mean we're we're kind
of at that stage right now where we've
invested so much time
yeah you're dead
[Music]
we've invested so much time and so much
love
and and passion in this project really
that um
it's going to be done when it's done i i
know it's as cliche as that sounds it's
like
this is going to be perfect when it's
released and and we're not going to
make any exceptions it totally makes
sense i mean
it's like a masterpiece i know a lot of
people were waiting for
um the trailer and when they saw the
updated trailer yesterday they went
crazy so that it's awesome to see that
kind of
love you know get pushed back into
something that you love
you know yeah and you know a lot of that
is kind of owed to
just the lineage that system shock has
which
spans as far as you know the bioshock
games
uh pray dishonored pretty much any
immersive sin that's come after that is
you know owes its existence to system
shock and
there's a lot of fans uh waiting for
this and
we know you're waiting very patiently
and we're doing our best to deliver
something that
that's going to be memorable and that
it's going to be worth the wait
cool well it's great having you on board
thank you so much stephen for
uh showing the game and talking about it
it's it's cool to like see how the
sausage is made and for folks in the
chat you know to
to learn about it too so um yeah shout
shout out um thank you guys how could we
find
more about your team and the game
um you can go to systemshock.com that's
the that's the easiest one
and we do actually still have a backer
kit open for those who still want to
back the project and and score some
really cool swag at the same time
we've got collectors editions t-shirts
art books all that stuff is up for
pre-order right now
and uh yeah if you just kind of want to
follow night dive studio you can
follow us on twitter it's night dive
studio because we ran out of characters
like you guys did
yeah gorilla click
i know how that is so yeah for sure
um but yeah thanks thanks for joining us
uh and everybody
go try out the demo yeah wish list it's
gonna be dope
cool thank you guys all right awesome
that was system shock you did really
well with the controller
yeah i did better i it this is i'm super
excited about this game
um this whole genre like he was saying
like the the games that have come
come after this it's had such a impact
on the industry
and um super excited that that they're
not going to release it until they're
ready
because this is a super important game
so
uh that's really cool yeah well let's uh
let's shout out our sponsors again
we got carlos bardu uh coming up with
the eternal cylinder i know you guys
were looking for in the chat we're
looking for that to roll you guys over
and it's coming up next uh shout out to
idea xbox razer
fully illustrated wilmer sound av
society
astro we got a razor machine here
they've been
dope um also shout out to ign
and id at xbox again uh
gamespot and twitch for really
supporting the gorilla collective
we couldn't have done it without their
help showing these
these games again um the these
independent game developers large and
small
came together to do this because there
was a lack of e3
and we wanted to get visibility uh for
you know the games that we've been
spending so much time
effort blood sweat and tears to make
yes please also if you have in your
heart of hearts contribute to unicef
in double acp or game heads through the
link below
um and we are going to be rolling
literally into the next game
yes here's the trailer for eternal
cylinder
far from here beyond the
furthest star
a cataclysm threatens an entire planet
but light shines
through the smallest of cracks
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
far from here in the path of destruction
no one survives alone
and that was the beautiful trailer for
the eternal cylinder
um we do have carlos on board to talk
about the game we're going to play the
game
hey what's up carlos hello how are you
guys
great great um the game looks amazing i
think the first time we played it
uh was at good shepherd's like hidden
area
at uh gamescom and it was so beautiful i
remember seeing the game
um like when you first start was it in
2015 2016 around 2015
2016 i did a a type of like a small
prototype i did with a colleague
yeah it wasn't expected to be like the
official next ace team
game that we were doing at the time it
was just a kind of a personal project
and we took it to a gdc
like to show it around but then it
started catching
the attention of people and was like wow
it seems like this is
more than we anticipated and it grew
into this
pretty large project i would say
definitely one of the biggest things
we've done today
so yeah it's been quite a trip the game
is so dope that people are accusing it
of breaking the stream
yes yesterday and we're gonna we're
gonna
break this one yeah it definitely we
hope so when the cylinder comes
run because we don't want this the
stream to be steamrolled
we are gonna be making a moat because
everyone's so good in the chat i know
everyone's talking
talking stuff in the chat right now
shout out to the chat for being very
hilarious and vocal
but we're gonna play the game sure
oh it's cool i hit continue
we're going to we're going to play in a
continued state it's going to be great
i can let you get the voice inside the
trevor's memory
yeah start start go to the main menu and
start from the beginning
yeah just walk us through it the you
know uh the gameplay and
what's going on so uh
it's a definitely different game it's a
game about
these little creatures which are being
introduced here in this intro cinematic
which
are the trebum the tremendous are
directly inspired by cubert
um we um it's
this funny little head creatures with a
trunk and two two legs very similar
but they have this ability to mutate and
eat things in the environment and
transforms you're
a family of these little creatures that
are born in this alienware
world as you see as soon as you like
exit the intro cinematic you start
right there and in right in front of the
cylinder and
and and they're tough that you appear in
this this very hostile alien world
and it's a survival game but not it's
not a survival game it's an adventure
game but not an adventure game it's
it's really something that's quite
different people have been comparing it
this war
but really nothing like sports at all
maybe the looks of some of the creature
designs and stuff like that but
uh it's its own thing it it
yeah this this feels really unique it's
very intuitive like how you have to
combine
um like different elements
things that you have to yeah yeah
if you look backwards uh you you start
and immediately you have this massive
cylinder that's crushing the whole world
you don't know what's going on
and one of the big difficulties we've
had with the project is definitely
the the technical aspect is it's pretty
big
in this project because we have uh
everything that's being destroyed here
is actually dynamic it's not that we
think that's
only for the we didn't only fake it for
the introduction
of the game at the scene like many games
like maybe have some very
cool starting uh setup where you had
like lots of
maybe particles and stuff but the truth
is for this game
the cylinder is rolling at times all the
time and it can
get too pretty it can go pretty fast so
we had to have all sorts of different
solutions for
uh static objects like uh solid objects
like rocks and things like
you can see kind of break and explode
but we also have the trees that bend and
and many different things the creatures
that can crush and start
yeah he was making me nervous kept
looking behind him i was like
look forward
at the beginning we had the cylinder
going like a at a stable speed and we
and people were dying in the very first
minutes of the game so we don't want
that to happen
um but right now that the cylinder has
stopped you starts to
start getting introduced into the basic
the first basic things that the creature
starts and
as you'll see you get these like kind of
weird grasshoppers
and they drop this little egg there and
if you eat it
and choose it you'll notice one of the
main features of the game
right now our little friend is eating
that
piece and you grow these grasshopper
legs which
allow you to sort of jump out of the
beach and sort of start exploring
and playing around so the game is
uh separated in a structure that's not
very
typical um compared to other titles in
in a sense that
yes it is procedurally um generated the
terrain
but at certain moments we have uh
the the game go into like pre-designed
uh areas where we want to further the
narration of the game where we want
further the story
and and uh do specific puzzles or
specific areas
so if you for instance if you you can
see that
the fish over there that's the one
that's swimming over there
if you can go and eat it try try go in
there and eat
yeah exactly if you go out and eat it
you'll notice that you'll acquire
another mutation
the mutations stack up stack on on each
other
not not all of them but now you have a
big body so
this allows you to have a bigger
inventory you have to be
this game has a lot of features you have
a stamina wheel
for swimming and all mutations can take
in the
can alter different aspects of the of
the trouble
in many ways so these aren't
okay sure no talk about this thing is
crazy looking
yeah that's one of the animals of the
game it's it's it's it's
they just wander around there those are
this one
they can try to roll roll over you and
so there's a lot of things that roll
over you in this game
[Laughter]
but we have like this whole ecosystem of
different alien creatures and
they're separate by different biomes so
we have
this is like the main what we call the
alien savanna biome
um and you go around there you go
you can go to the first elder there's an
elder over there
who's gonna introduce you to one of us i
like the role
yeah we made we made rock of ages yes
that's what's great
yeah i was gonna say it's like
reminiscent we like rolling so
that's cool
the trebum kneeling so as i was saying
there's different biomes with different
totally different types of environments
and there's different creatures that
you'll encounter there
they range in scale and size some are
predators some are herbivores some are
very dangerous some are
not dangerous at all we're trying to
make this kind of ecosystem in which the
player gets to explore but uh
what makes it unique also is the aspect
of how progression
goes on with the cylinders sort of
forcing you to move forward and we have
to sort of build
the world as as you
move forward so we constantly have to
load
in the environment the inner voice said
run
the towers would not stop the cylinder
unless they were
so cool look at these guys so now you
should go to the tower that you see
you should roll to any of those two
towers you can check you see the big red
beam
yeah go that that direction for instance
either of those
he's getting nervous you see that again
a little freaking out the music is
intended today yeah
yeah you have to reach that tower over
there
oh this is the very beginning so you're
you're basically learning the
step on the symbol or the cylinder
later on in the game the cylinder gets
this red glow and it
really catches a lot of speed i mean it
goes really really fast so
you're basically racing it's racing your
way to
for your life and with all these little
creatures you have to
really really run away oh look at that
guy
yeah that's the way we friendly we call
him the chomper
yeah you should stand there and let him
eat you
i have to i have to stay on the blue oh
i've got to stop the cylinder
right stop it there we go
wow so the structure of the game is a
little bit like that but not entirely
you have to remember this is a kind of
the onboarding aspect part of the game
so here's a little bit more peaceful
there are creatures that can actually
kill you
uh but to the right you'll notice there
was this kind of
snowy area that you can go over there so
that's
that's a small brief introduction to one
of the different biomes so
if you go there you'll notice that the
treble will start shaking
and because it's cold and you're going
to actually start losing health but if
you move to the left over there
yeah i'm i'm just cheating here i'm
telling you you can see those like puffy
balls near to those
corals things that are right behind you
you could go
right back uh to the behind you right
behind you
uh where you see that sort of coral
things coral
oh this like yeah those turn around
okay turn around
okay sorry there's a little bit of a
delay i think when you
okay yeah there you see the puppy purple
balls to the left
to the left the
exactly you can eat one of them so not
all ingredients
give you a mutation some of them do some
of them don't there's a
reason for that there's a
so this is a temporary mutation but yeah
you
later you can make it permanent but now
you have a coat of fur so this allows
you to
explore in this area and you can find
other trebuks
who will join you in your adventure so
there's a lot of different aspects of
how we
allow people to explore different areas
so this is the jumper but this is the
furry one from the
the snow areas you have to be careful oh
cool
he will eat you he will eat you yes okay
he's not as vegetarian as i thought he
might be no no no
that's cool and when you get a bunch of
when you get the different travels you
could switch between them
right yeah for instance there's one over
there
oh cool and now you have a little a
partner who will follow you
and that's a a central aspect of the
game is
uh getting another tripod and growing
like this herd of little creatures
which is gonna follow you during the
adventure and you can switch between
them
and you can stack on on them their own
powers and their own abilities
so it's a game it's a
again it's a narrative game where you
have there's a reason for all this is
just not a procedurally
generated sort of world where you get to
doof around
but that that is a a lot of fun in the
game there's a purpose
that there's more than a purpose there's
a reason for
for for why why the cylinder is here
who you are what's going on in this
world
and there's tons of depth in this game i
mean there's the exploration
there is even when i when i was trying
it earlier you have like a
a stamina system too where you have to
make sure that
you're eating and that kind of thing
right and you're yeah
that gets introduced later in the game
it's a little bit uh
like you you get the energy pouch and
the stomach where you have to
you have to feed your creatures
so if you jump there you can get that
egg if i can
jump up here yep you can just just jump
up there and you can grab that egg
with a now if you go to where you can
see this this little
behind the other way you can see that
thing there where you can heat the egg
if you leave it there
oh that's another trouble
uh yes wait no if you stand there it's
gonna work
okay there it is so it's heating the egg
and that would allow you to get
another little friendly little truck you
can actually name them um
i don't know if it's gonna work with a
with a controller now but so
i think we're gonna just leave it at
that okay
he's gonna name it me thanks
i appreciate it
i look extra confused
that's me
[Laughter]
so the the the friendly treble that they
they help you in this
it's not only about getting more of
these and
allowing your family to grow it also uh
there's also certain puzzles which will
have requirements of how many creatures
you need in order to unlock the areas
uh if we want to see more of the content
you can go
to the left of this large mountain uh
and you're going to see one of the
these giant serpent creatures which are
called the chihuahua
am i going the right way oh no the other
way the other way
okay to the left of the mountain and
just keep on going
left of it two left left left left go
left left side that way the other way
this way that way okay
amazing i'm the most annoying yeah he's
going the opposite way on purpose
and naming his friends troubles
[Laughter]
they're on the adventure with me oh wow
oh that's sick
yikes so right right beneath this
colossal creature
there's a sort of entry to a
uh interior one one of what we call the
elder caves because there's basically
these
uh indoor environments where you can
had been built explore more here you get
more introduction to the story of the
game and how
that in this love
now you could have the way you resolved
this this part of the
the beginning of the game was getting
these three specific trebuks
but there are other in the outdoor
environment which
you can get in different ways and see
and discover other mutations
and that's the idea that people
different people will will solve this in
different ways
that's cool
there's a lot of backstory and history
that you've created for this game
yeah well one of the games we're most
well known
for is you know clash and a lot of a lot
of people like uh
appreciate the the type of surreal
worlds that we create but also the
surreal stories that we
we make for those worlds so
here for instance um you start getting
some
some puzzles so you have this strange
door with an
ancient statue with this box shaped
statue
and you're getting introduced to this
strange ingredient
so it's it's all part of the the the
puzzle
we have a compendium for creatures
food at the moment you don't have the
mutation which allows you to add
uh creatures into
into your compendium but you'll notice
this area opened up
and if you can go there
one thing you haven't showed that much
is the uh
throwing water with with your trunk so
with the right trigger you can shoot
information hidden away in the web of
them
you should eat that one okay you should
definitely eat that one
he's slipping down on the stairs that's
when i would laugh
i thought i thought he was transforming
ah there he is nice so now you are part
part of the puzzle you are now part of a
part of the puzzle so you would have
tried to enter
enter that that socket before
it wouldn't have opened so now with the
square trap you can
access to this area and you find
yourself with
grumble the elder
inside the cave the trevor found a
living
so the game is it has been waiting in
this chamber since you're
in this kind of alien world at the
beginning we didn't have the narrator in
the game
uh that's something that came later
during
this game has been a lot of
experimentation that if you looked at
the original design document
uh there's the the core concept of the
game is
there but we started seeing what things
worked and what things didn't work
uh through a process of discovery
because it's very different to anything
and anything else that we've ever done
or we really can't drop our parallels
with other titles so uh for instance the
narrator was something that came later
on he
he's actually part of the story he's not
just there to help players but he's
he's an actual character so yeah it's
it's a very
unique game and we're we're really
excited about it
the game liz is really gorgeous it's so
open there's so many things to do and
expands it it's it's very expansive
um when are you releasing do you have a
release date yet
no we do not have a release date we have
an idea of when we might be able to
really
some people will get mad yes totally
understand that from experience
let's not upset the internet yeah more
than we already have
yeah but yeah it's it's really awesome
um
can you wish list it and and where will
you be able to find it
yes it can be wish listed on the epic
given store uh we're also launching
on uh playstation and xbox but i don't
think
wishlist there um it will be a
simultaneous
uh release but uh yeah we don't know
when
cool cool how can we find out more about
the eternal cylinder
there oh yeah i should call out that
there's a beta a
beta you just have to register at
eternalcylinder.com
and yeah and if you want to know more
about ace team ace team dot cl we're at
chilean studio so dot com
cl uh to check more about cool
eternal cylinder and other extinctions
thank you so much
for hopping on board carlos it's awesome
to see this game i was so happy that we
were able to
to showcase the trailer the other day
and then actually get to play so people
could see
exactly what it is especially since it
was blowing up in the chat
and the cylinder did not destroy us
today
we're rolling out with the cylinder i'm
also disappointed that it did
yeah i thought
i thought this was one i did well at
yeah there's going to be means we're
making them so yeah okay
i'm looking forward to them all right
thank you so much
that was the eternal cylinder um the
game is is gorgeous you did okay
thank you for naming me uh one of the
troubles i
oh yeah i appreciate it well yeah um
this is a really creative game this is
really
amazing there's something in the water
in chile yeah definitely
um yeah it's it's been an amazing
experience we have one trailer
that came from new blood just in that we
want to showcase before we head out
let's roll the new blood trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah inside last are you
welcome welcome
and that was gloomwood from new blood
thank you so much new blood for dropping
an exclusive trailer of the gorilla
collective uh the gorilla collective is
now over
this it's been an amazing experience
thanks for hopping on board alex
oh yeah in this amazing space at wilmer
sound
uh we want to thank um all of our
partners again
ign gamespot valve um
i said ign twice kind of funny of sh of
course
id at xbox astro razer everybody who's
been working with us
uh ryan behind the boards and tracy and
everyone else
it's been an amazing experience now
we're gonna go back to greg
peace and that's it ladies and gentlemen
the gorilla collective is done over
three days we've shown you nearly 90
games from almost
80 teams on behalf of the mix kind of
funny and
every creator who took part in this
event we cannot thank you enough
we hope you all have a fantastic not e3
e3 i don't know what are we calling
there's just showcases and events every
day now but for real
from the bottom of our hearts thank you
so much for your support and know
until next time it's been our pleasure
to serve you
you